six o'clock in the morning so I was
doing my back exercises how you do every
morning pretty much I was preparing a
class because they had accosted later
that day who have nine o'clock actually
of course I was surprised by their
bicycle lots of people could get the
prize always surprised its pleasant
surprise I was kind of shocked I went in
to talk to my wife I wanted to tell my
wife and I told her well you're gonna
have to go to Sweden and she said what
for and I said because I got the Nobel
Prize and she said no and I said yes she
said no because she the phone didn't
ring in her room so she didn't hear it
she thought I was putting her on but in
the end she then she started crying